Vamos a ver si podemos
resolver este problema, dice,
Arturo va a construir
3 estantes para su padre.
Él tiene un pedazo de madera
de 12 pies de largo,
del cual, quiere que el estante superior
sea medio pie
más pequeño que el estante de en medio...
déjame tomar colores
para que poco a poco
vayamos utilizando los datos...
Del cual...
déjenme agarrar otro color...
quiere que el estante superior
sea medio pie más pequeño
que el estante de en medio...
muy bien, este es otro dato
y con otro color voy a poner
que el estante inferior sea medio
pie más pequeño
que 2 veces
la longitud del estante superior.
Y bueno, lo que nos dice
la pregunta es lo siguiente,
si Arturo quiere usar los 12 pies
de madera que tiene,
¿cuánto debe medir cada estante?
Muy bien,
ya tenemos aquí el problema,
ahora lo que vamos a hacer
es definir variables,
como necesitamos saber
la longitud de nuestros 3 estantes,
uno superior, uno en medio
y uno inferior,
entonces vamos a ponerles nombre.
Ahora lo primero que voy a hacer
es definir variables,
voy a decir que "t" es la longitud
del estante superior...
la longitud del estante superior, que "m"
es la longitud del estante de en medio...
"m" es la longitud del estante de en medio...
la longitud del estante de en medio...
ya tengo el superior,
ya tengo el de en medio
y por último que "b"
es la longitud del estante inferior...
"b" va a ser el estante inferior...
del estante inferior...
Y bueno,
¿qué me dicen estos datos?
El primer dato lo podemos escribir en matemáticas
de la forma siguiente,
dice,
Arturo quiere que el estante superior
sea medio pie
más pequeño
que el estante de en medio,
esto quiere decir que
"t" tiene que ser igual
al estante de en medio,
que es "m"
menos medio pie  porque tiene que ser
más pequeño que el estante de en medio,
entonces "t" es igual a
"m" menos 1/2 ó 0.5.
Muy bien, después el siguiente dato
me dice lo siguiente,
Arturo también quiere que el estante inferior
sea medio pie más pequeño
que dos veces la longitud del estante superior,
es decir, que el estante inferior "b",
debe ser medio pie
más pequeño
que dos veces la longitud del estante superior...
dos veces la longitud del estante superior,
es lo mismo que tomarme la longitud
del estante superior que es "t"
y multiplicarlo por 2,
porque van a ser 2 veces esa longitud.
Entonces me quedaría,
que "b" es igual a "2t"menos 1/2 pie,
es decir, menos 1/2.
Muy bien, entonces
ya tenemos, que el estante superior
sea 1/2 pie más pequeño que el
estante de en medio,
eso quiere decir que "t"
es igual a "m" menos 1/2
y después que el estante inferior sea
1/2 pie más pequeño
que dos veces
la longitud del estante superior,
eso quiere decir que "b",
es igual a "2t" menos 1/2.
Ahora nos falta una ecuación y la última ecuación
la voy a sacar de qué dice que Arturo
va a usar los 1
2 pies de madera completos
y por lo tanto, con estos 12 pies de madera,
tiene que hacer los 3 estantes,
el superior, el de en medio y el inferior,
es decir que "t" más "m" más "b",
esto tiene que ser igual a 12...
a 12 pies...
Muy bien, y ahora que ya tenemos
las tres ecuaciones,
¿cómo resolvemos este problema?
Y bueno, a mi lo que se me ocurre
es poner todo en términos de "m",
porque aquí dice que "t"
es igual a "m" menos 1/2,
entonces voy a usar
esta ecuación de aquí,
para que cada vez que yo vea una "t",
ponga en lugar de "t", "m" menos 1/2.
Por lo tanto, aquí tengo que "b",
es igual a "2t" menos 1/2,
pero, en lugar de "t" voy a poner "m" menos 1/2,
lo que voy a hacer es una sustitución,
entonces en lugar de "t",
voy a poner "m" menos 1/2 y entonces,
¿qué me quedaría de "b"?
"b" sería igual a 2 por "t", es decir,
2 por "m" menos 1/2,
porque recuerda que "t",
vale igual a "m" menos 1/2,
entonces 2 por "m" menos 1/2
y a esto le vamos a quitar -1/2...
muy bien, ¿y esto qué me queda?
Me va a quedar, 2 por "m", es "2m"
y después 2 por -1/2,
entonces "b" es igual a
"2m" menos
2 por 1/2, 2 por 1/2 es 1,
entonces -1 menos -1/2
ó dicho de otra manera,
"b" es igual a "2m" menos 3/2,
-1 menos 1/2 es lo mismo que -3/2,
entonces a esto le quitamos 3/2.
Y entonces ya tengo que "t"
es igual a "m" menos 1/2,
que "b" es igual a "2m" menos 3/2,
entonces ¿por qué no sustituyo
en esta ecuacionsota que tenemos aquí
el valor de "t" y el valor
de "b" en términos de "m"?
Y me va a quedar,
que "t", es decir "m" menos 1/2,
más "m", más "b", pero en lugar de "b"
recuerda que voy a poner "2m" menos 3/2,
vamos a usar también esta
otra ecuación que tengo aquí.
Entonces tengo que "b" es igual a "2m" menos 3/2,
y me va a quedar, "m" menos 1/2
más  "m" más "2m" menos 3/2,
esto es lo que vale "b",
esto tiene que ser igual a 12.
¿Y qué crees?
Ya tengo una ecuación con solamente una incógnita,
pase de tener una ecuación con tres incógnitas,
a tener una ecuación
con solamente una incógnita,
después de que sustituí el valor de "t"
y el valor de "b".
Y ahora si, tengo
una  "m", "2m", más "2m" son "4m" totales,
"4m" y a esto,
le tengo que quitar -1/2 menos 3/2,
menos 1/2 menos 3/2, son -4/2,
lo cual es -2,
entonces -1/2 menos 3/2,
esto, todo esto se reduce a -2,
"4m" menos 2
esto tiene que ser igual a 12.
Y ahora si, de aquí está
muy fácil despejar para "m",
porque si lo queremos hacer
es obtener el valor de "m",
primero hay que sumar 2 de ambos lados
de la ecuación, de tal manera
que si yo tomo otro color y aquí sumo 2
y aquí también sumo 2,
entonces,
¿qué me va a quedar?
Del lado izquierdo me queda
"4m" porque estos dos se van
y del lado derecho me queda 12 más 2,
lo cual es 14.
Y ahora si divido todo entre 4,
voy a obtener el valor
de "m", todo entre 4...
todo entre 4...
y me va a quedar que "m"
es igual a 14/4,
pero 14/4 es lo mismo que 7/2,
entonces 7/2,
"m" vale 7/2 y al menos,
ya sé cuál es la longitud en pies
que debe de tener el estante de en medio,
el estante de en medio
debe de tener 7/2 de pies de longitud.
Y bueno, ya que sé "m",
¿ahora cómo saco "t"?
Pues "t" es lo mismo que "m" menos 1/2,
es decir, 7/2 menos 1/2,
lo cual por cierto es 6/2
que es 3,
el estante superior
debe de medir 3 pies,
su longitud debe de ser 3 pies
y bueno, ya tengo a "m", que por cierto, 7/2,
es exactamente lo mismo que 3 entero 1/2...
déjame ponerlo aquí...
"m" es lo mismo que 7/2
ó 3 enteros 1/2 de pies.
Y bueno, ya tengo a "m", ya tengo a "t",
puedo de aquí obtener el valor de "b", pues sí,
"b" es igual a "2t" menos 1/2,
es decir 2 por 3 menos 1/2,
lo cual es 6 menos 1/2,
lo cual son 5 enteros 1/2.
La longitud del estante inferior,
debe de ser de 5 pies 1/2 y es más,
hasta lo podemos verificar,
porque 5 1/2 más 3 enteros 1/2
es lo mismo que 9
y 9 más 3 es 12
y por otra parte,
el estante superior es 1/2 pie más pequeño,
que el estante de en medio,
que era justo uno de los datos
y después obtenemos
que el estante inferior
es medio pie más pequeño
que 2 veces el estante superior.